هنا في مقاطعة سانت تشارلز ، نبحث دائمًا
عن طرق جديدة ومثيرة
لتقوية قسمنا لتقديم
خدمة أفضل لمجتمعنا لدينا
وحدة SWAT للدراجات النارية التي تعمل بالكلاب ، لكننا نحاول
تطوير وحدة جديدة تمامًا هي الأولى من
نوعها في البلاد  حيوانات وحدة الألبكة التي
تتعلم الشرطة
والمساعدة المجتمعية ، لدينا منطقة ريفية كبيرة يجب
تغطيتها في مقاطعة سانت تشارلز
وستساعدنا هذه الألبكة على فعل ذلك بالضبط بحيث
يسهل تدريبها على أنها غير متوقعة
لأن معظم الناس لا يربطونها
بالشرطة  يمكنهم الذهاب إلى الكثير من الأماكن التي
لا يمكنك الوصول إليها في سيارة ، فهي ليست
وحدة باترول مركبة تمامًا ولا يمكنك
ركوبها ، ومن الواضح أن هناك بعض مكامن الخلل التي يجب
حلها ولكننا متحمسون حقًا
لهذه الوحدة ،  مغير اللعبة